欢迎收看赵华
我是赵华 我是艾伦
没想到我们也有今天
亏为三个月
台股又创历史新高了
恭喜
可是每一次创新高
大家就会担心
是不是又咕噜咕噜咕噜要滚下来
应该不会啦
不是嘛
我们你看6月在担心
7月在担心
8月又要担心
现在创历史新高了
因为上一次创历史新高
也是收一个黑K
那今天更猛了
今天本来涨800多点
结果最后只涨80几点
所以今天拉了个800点的上影线
上影线800点
好家在
我觉得是量缩
量缩还可以接收
然后又要放假
所以大家今天可能钱卖卖
礼拜四放假钱才拿到钱
提加二
所以我觉得还可以接受
下个礼拜再来看
因为台股可能有台股
自己中秋廉价的状况
可是如果以昨天晚上
美股来说的话
是个个有表现猛将一大堆
是
好 所以我们就来解读一下
如果今天只是一个
接钱卖压的话
那接下来是不是好戏
在后头呢
今天48601
好 然后但是呢
我们先把节过了
因为看来今天
确实有一些节线调节
但是涨力强
尤其是像CPU有好消息
半导体论坛
这礼拜有好消息
还有传习会等等的
都有一些支撑的力道
所以我觉得目前来说
息也升完了嘛
最痛的那一刀也砍完了
对嘛 砍完了
然后油价也跌了嘛
对 油价跌了
所以我觉得就目前来说
先不管技术面会不会跌啦
至少我觉得事件性来讲
应该短线上是比较少利空的
對 所以我們就來看一下
不只利空少
也有一些利多的支持
沒錯Meta推出了
它最新的AI代理叫做Muse
Muse 沒錯
然後自己股價就漲了11%
為什麼 因為它在美國那邊的APP
免費下載是綁手
就是它好像推出快兩禮拜
然後就熔燈綁手
對 下載超過250萬次
所以這件事情也讓大家覺得
AI其實是還是需求很大的
而且它是什麼代理人
對 Asian AI
就幫你可以下訂單採購
對 就大概是兩三個月前
我們有來講過的
就是之後你一支手機
你看到誰的演唱會了
他會幫你追蹤
幫我搶票
對 他會直接
你不用跟他講
對 你就給你設定好
先幫你追蹤
時間到他就自己買了
所以你就突然發現信用卡
就會跳通知
被扣款了
這樣好嗎
所以其實我覺得蠻方便的
對嘛 只是你會學莫名其妙
怎麼被扣錢
難怪亞馬遜其實不讓這個代理人AI
去他的網站買東西
是這樣子是不是
他說不知道後面是誰啊
有可能
對啊 如果這被入侵的話應該蠻嚴重
好 那不管怎麼樣
我們發現這件事情又帶動了AI的一個反攤
包含像是Meta
然後像ARM也自己長起來了
Intel有12%
AMD也市值第一次達到了1兆美元
創歷史新高的股價
是的 所以整體來講
昨天的美股
尤其是半導體這一塊
它是全面紅
是
沒有錯
這也是帶動間台灣股市
為什麼可以開高的原因
開高會開高
盆中走低是走低
那納斯達克也創下
6月2號也來新高
所以目前來說
我覺得科技股
最近又重燃了一波火勢起來
是 幸好有美國科技股也跟上來
要不然我們自己在那裡吹風
挺冷的
是的
這一次終於不是
我們去給他們帶下來
不是說向下去找他們
是他們上來找我們
沒錯
再來另外一個
还有这个光通讯的大展
有开幕
在欧洲
是的
跟Lumantum
有高通有康宁
秀了D2D的互联
那瞄准的就是AI横向
扩展的架构
所以这些东西呢
就基本上
大家就稍微自己看一下
那图也结在这边
因为它这边东西
都是比较技术面上
技术产业的东西
就是他们自己
秀一些肌肉出来
那这一年来讲
其实对于目前
整个CPU的族群性
我觉得应该都还是一些
持续性的利多
只不过最近的CPU的
手势有一點分析
然後老的CPU稍微
沒有這麼有活力
年輕一點的CPU比較有活力
我們等下下一段會講
所以這個是近期又有一個
相關的CPU的利多
對 好
其實主要往上
美股的CPU也是有反應的
是的 所以我覺得
CPU來講應該都還是
可以持續好好去關注的
再來看到另外一個
就是剛剛提到了國外的
我們講一下我們國內的
台積電要拼先進封裝
它也兼顧到國外
因為北美的OIP論壇
也要展開就在這裡辦
所以這也辦應該台積電
和相關技術的東西會很多才對
所以應該還是持續會有一些
看有沒有大家解讀利多的訊息
可是今天台積電收最低
沒辦法 今天到來
今日最低
是的 好
可是我們的這個VCC
有說了我們股價要趕快追上聯發科
請問是要上去追到發哥5000
還是發哥要下來找台積電
应该要上去吧
如果它要5000
那就是台积电要翻倍
就是台积电当然希望往上追
所以台积电如果要翻倍
那我们台股至少
指数也要涨个80%吧
我们先看3000好不好
翻倍真的是
所以目前来说
它有纠团设先进封装的中心
会在高雄白浦的
白浦产业园区
然后会号召本土的设备
跟材料的业者去做进驻
基本上还是持续一条龙的供应链
所以我觉得这一些未来
应该都还是从里面找商机
就是不只是台积电
台积电跟他的好朋友们
应该都可以好好注意一下
这个是持续上
经这几天的一些新闻
给大家观察一下
你会发现AI相关的都反应
就是大家都往正向表态
所以我觉得也是真的很神奇
你看上礼拜
上上礼拜我们还在讲
要暂缓发展
而且很闷
就是成交量很萎缩
又担心AI
又担心升息
然后今天油价跌很重嘛
油价那个什么
西德州剩95块
对 原本100多
然后那个布兰特也是
跌到100元附近
所以整个科技股就标起来了
瞬间好像利空通通不见
对 就一周的时间
那台湾股市呢
我们可以看到
今天是48601
盘中有突破了
这个6月的历史新高
但是收盘价其实呢
是没有突破的
那就等于是挑战失败
这样算挑战失败啊
挑战失败
对 那挑战失败过程中
还拉了一个800点左右的上影线
所以这个短线上
应该就会是一个明确要整理的讯号
那不过这个整理讯号我们有说嘛
高档如果再配报大量
那可能就是涨完了的讯号
上次就有一点这个味道
是的
那可是呢
这一次其实是没有报大量的
这一次还算合理的量
对 所以我觉得还可以接受
但是单纯就这一根来讲
我个人觉得短期
应该也是要出现整理的讯号
不过这个整理呢
一方面今天是离拜二嘛
那今天卖股票
离拜四领得到钱
对 离拜四可以拿回钱
对 可是你明天卖跟后天卖
都基本上是结后才能领到钱
报股过节 报钱过节
是的 所以大家可能会在今天
会有做了一些
结钱的T加2的卖压调整
那一方面就是有些交易者呢
喜欢是创新高开始卖股票
对 所以有一些获利卖压也好
或者说有一些结钱的调整也好
那造就了今天有一个上影线
我觉得是还可以接受的
那成交量
重点是成交量没有爆得很夸张
还是在一兆左右
那我觉得这个状态之下
就还算OK
那OK过程中
我们基本上上引线嘛
所以还是要注意整理
那有几个位置
大家可以稍微观察一下
首先是这个前高
这个前高是47600
其实就大概300点左右
因为今天47800嘛
所以大概差200到300点
那这个位置是原本的压力区
所以突破转支撑
那再来就是均线
接下来要上完了
上万过程会形成一些支撑
就是有一些助长的效果
那只要碰到了一些支撑的支撑区
或者说关键的一些上万均线
有出现了止跌的讯号
那我觉得合理都有机会
再重新挑战这个高点
那如果再做突破
那这个行情就是持续墊高了
所以目前来说我觉得短线确实
可能明后天成交量
应该会稍微萎缩一点
因为要放假了
那刚好来一个价跌量缩
然后开始酝酿可能放假后的新行情
所以下礼拜只要出现一些
更好的讯号出现
其实我觉得应该都是站在买方
对 那目前来说
只会看短线要休息
但长线是多头
我觉得应该没有问题
再来另外是贵买
贵买今天也很可惜啊
都上影线
但是收盘价确实占上了
这个414
对 所以我会认为
它是一个相形的突破
那这应该都会是
对长线来讲是好事
当然都上影线
所以上影线我觉得
短线要休息应该都没问题
应该都
合理的
对啦 几率比较高
那整理的过程
只要不要有一个什么
突然明天補大量 1.5兆下來
那這個就不行了
可是應該不太會
所以我覺得就是
這兩天沉澱一下
因為要放假
可能我覺得交易的活絡度也會降低
那等放完假之後
再來看一下量等跟形態上
有沒有更進一步向上去做發展
反而是今天一開盤
那個800點有把我嚇一跳
大家好猛喔
對啊 很可惜
尾盤其實賣壓真的滿重的
對 那另外一盤就台積電
台大電說錯了
台大電呢
在昨天來一個紅K
這紅K很重要 為什麼
這個是6月
一次 兩次 三次
到了這一次第五次
終於站上季線
所以我覺得是一個非常重要的訊號
就是這60天買的人
終於賺錢了
那賺錢了這裡做突破
剩下挑戰這個地方
這個地方是一個頸線位置
所以這裡要做突破
這WD就確立了
那我覺得已經打兩隻腳了
剩下是高點要去做突破
它都低檔有量
然後低檔有人想要買它
果然是好公司
是的 所以我覺得它這邊開始有在
展現台達電應該要有的樣子
因為開始Q是也要出貨了
對 所以我覺得
之前的一些兩綠問題
或者說出貨低延的問題
應該要開始慢慢消化掉
再來應該是光寶科
光寶科這一波走勢
比台達電來的強很多
先創新高的是它
是 那不過在後面這一陣子
也是一路整理到270塊
開始逐底
那今天很可惜
来到300又开高走低
但我认为这边已经出现了一个
开始足底的讯号
所以在这个位置上
我觉得光宝科
上升趋势线跌破了
那开始走整理
但周琳来到这个位置
应该也要在这边做足底
所以我觉得有一个赚培比的
或者说非常好抓停存的位置出现了
就是2007跌破
因为跌破这边就是导恩型
可是如果这边没跌破
那后面
我觉得光宝科的产业的状态
应该不会输台下电
对 所以我觉得后续应该是值得期待
这个是两个电源的
全资股
顺便跟大家稍微分享一下
技术面上的状态
好 当然台积电今天
收的比较低是有点可惜
但是也把空间等于
让出来给大家
后续还是很值得期待
也可能是有这个
提款效应的关系
所以广告回来
我们会继续聊下去
有这么多的好消息
有一个事情很特别
Intel为什么大涨
有人说Intel是因为
跟友达结盟做CPU
我第一次听到
有台湾的厂商跟美股
就是合作是涨在美股身上
当然友达今天也很强
所以延伸这个话题我们来看一下
到底整体的CPU状况如何呢
OK来吧
这个很奇妙的事情
当然我不觉得单纯是因为
友达和Intel要合作
Intel大涨
但是因为确实友达也很强
Intel也很强
是的
這英特爾昨天
12%的漲停我們是漲停板沒錯 所以我覺得可是我覺得應該也沒有因為這些半導體也很強對啦 所以我說不應該只是因為這樣可能剛好有這個新聞出現
那有傳出來
英特爾吸手友達要強攻CPO
先進封裝這一塊
所以又有一個利多給了友達
那友達這兩天的股價
都是漲停板的
那我們今天來講的
剛有提到嘛
最近的老CPO
除了可能全新之外
那普遍的
譬如說什麼波羅威
聯亞
或者是說這種上全 光盛
其實股價當然前面有反彈
但是現階段比較溫吞一點點
可是有一些新的CPU
開始在陸續強勢起來
就是擴散出來
甚至說它的股價比較便宜
幾十塊
沒錯 什麼光頂 電源
真的很猛
對 然後還有什麼聯翼光
對 所以反而是這一波的新的CPU
反而股價比較強一點
擴散效應又來了
對 所以大家反而還是會喜歡
新的題材
因為可能友達也轉型嘛
台表科轉型嘛
穩帽是沒有轉型
但穩帽也就還是
近期的表現還可以
林光通也是有說要做FAU
所以股價也是底部出現了一個
兩根左右的漲停板
那我們今天來跟大家講的
就是前面這四位
稍微來看一下
目前的一些題材跟技術面上的走勢
友達其實他本來就跟群創
是做一樣的面板
其實他們本業也有利多
因為中國這邊也傳要漲價
然後他們的價動率降低
所以不只是供給變少
然後單價也變高
所以以本業來講應該還不錯
再來另外一個就是
群創它有FOPOP跟CPU
那友達就比較偏向CPU一點點
友達又傳可能跟台積電合作
是啊 中科廠可能會賣給台積電
對 3.5跟7.5
然後再來是群創是強上半年
然後友達反而題材在下半年之後發酵
一樣的題材
一模一樣 跟台積電合作
先后的顺序
现在是强在友达上
对 所以大家如果你去看群创
群创其实是被季线压着
然后股价是稍微比较温吞一点点
可是友达就因为有一些利多
然后又卖场又一些借钱
有借很多钱
然后跟英特尔又合作
所以股价最近的表现
这两天成交的应该都是台股最大
但它今天创下了历史的最大量
你会关注这个事情吗
有涨停我就不关注
对
今天幸好它有锁住
有有打开过
中間一直開開光光
洗了100多萬張的成交量
沒錯
這太嚇完了
所以我覺得接下來走勢
應該都還是盤中
都要注意震盪
100多萬張
對 我覺得隔日充跟當充
一定超多人
這個這麼好充
量這麼大
不過至少技術面上
N字型
然後也突破了
今年7月的高點
所以我覺得形態上
又收漲停
應該沒有太多問題
不過短線當然
越來越多人知道
它的非常活潑
是 所以我覺得
交易的人会变多
那就要看一下筹码的变化
跟形态上有没有转弱
譬如说明天
这成交量这么粗
然后开高走低黑K
这么粗是要200万
太可怕了吧
不要说不可能
他最近这么吸睛
然后如果有上影线
那记得做一些调整
好 大家一定要留意
对 没错
所以我觉得目前来说
有达两根掌停码
应该N字形
大家就可以再稍微关注一下
是 应该给你一个奖状
忘记了
上次有讲
那再另外一个就是台表科
哎呦 怎么会轮到他
台湾表面黏著科技
我們都叫他表哥
表哥以前股性很不舒服
沒錯 其實他就是做代工
對嘛 他就是我把東西給你
原物料要給你
我幫你把這些東西
焊接到板子上面
對 那目前來說
台表科有接到
Cohenium跟AOI的訂單
對 那這些都是
毛利率比他本業來的高
另外一個他也有接到
美光跟常新存儲的訂單
就是要記憶體封裝
它也幫你把東西都黏上去
這些東西呢 毛利率也不低
你怎麼會發現它咧
因為表哥的範圍
本來就很廣 黏黏黏黏黏
對 因為表哥其實在前面
古災之前
他那一波其實炒的題材是一樣的
他有凶過一段時間
他那個時候
就有接到那個AOI的
Cohering的
然後再來就還有像類似正文
網通那一塊
也都有類似接到一樣的題材
我覺得形態上
今天這個漲停
也出現了一個N字型的走勢
對 所以我覺得這邊
應該都還是一個不錯的狀態
那成交量也放出來了
對 所以我覺得
都可以持續觀察一下
如果有回落均線跟上
大家可以去注意一下新的買電
是 就是表哥的部分
再來一個就是瑞萱
他也是比較有趣的
是 對 他之前也是從那種十多塊
就忽然狂噴說有CPO
沒錯 那這一陣子呢
瑞萱他其實之前也是做
電子消費性代工
所以也没什么钱可以赚
显示器啊
对
那不过这一次呢
传说有跟
不是传啦
就是新闻有写啊
就是有做到波若威的shuffle box
没错 帮忙他做代工
那后面这个对于他营收贡献来讲
应该会值得期待
因为他的营收其实
以本业来讲是比较疲弱一点的
对 那这一波修正
目前到这个地方
这边也是一个恩赐行
那到这个地方呢
到这里为止
其实都还维持一个上升趋势的结构
可是短线上确实
在这个地方遇到了一些阻力了
然后今天跌破五日均线
所以这边开始在震荡的时候
前低要守好
那这边走一个整理
那走整理前低如果有守好
那上去的时候
这边要做突破
做突破这个形态就会打出来
新的多方就会继续做延伸
所以上阵趋势还在
这个地方短线要做一些挑战
看能不能挑战过去
挑战过去就安全了
对 所以目前来说
瑞萱也遇到一些整理
那这两天黑K都亮缩
所以我觉得也还可以接受
那就等这个均线慢慢跟上
有没有一些助长的效果
这个是瑞旋的部分
也是偏转机股
没错
这个也是转机题材股
另外一个就是稳豹
好
这个就比较正统了
对不对
这个零花音等等的
然后也逐渐从
这个传统的消费性电子
走向AI领域了
是的
这个之前
这个以三五族来讲的话
其实联雅应该是最强的
那不过这一波是全新最强
而且全新股价是超过文貌的
这个也是蛮有趣的
本来文貌是先领先的
是的 后面就发现
其实就有比较不一样一点
可能全新跟联雅在涨的是
所谓的零化音
比较纯一点点
文貌就没有到纯的零化音
目前来说它有相关的化合物半导体
微波通讯
有光源键的代工
养猪的都卖掉了
之前大概就是比较旧的题材
目前来说
整個表現上已經開始進入一個量產
所以營收應該有機會競爭
然後一成以上跟毛利率應該會維持在三成以上
其實我覺得都還算是有在成長的
再來就是技術面的部分
目前短線上聯亞是一個明確的休息的走勢
然後全新是高漲整理
不過穩帽這邊有慢慢拉出一個N字型的走勢
這裡是第一段
大家一起漲的時候
然後開始走休息
然後這個時候又是大家一起漲的時候
然後全新就自己上去了
穩帽就在這邊走整理
整理的過程呢
碰到了一樣上升趨勢的位置
這兩點連成一線
就開始有一個新的行情
那這個行情來到這個地方
它今天收盤價
其實是有站上前高的
所以呢N字形應該有機會
繼續向上去做延伸
但是波度就會比較緩一點
我覺得穩帽就反而是
如果你成本拉得比較開的
那我覺得抱起來還滿舒服的
就是它整理的時候
至少它整個趨勢慣性
拉得非常明顯
也就是說如果你要做一個
停利或停損
那就是月线做跌破
然后呢
或者是高档的时候
走回落又爆了一个大量
才去做调整就好
目前的形态
我觉得都没有太多问题
大家可以去参考一下
都是多方的结构
好 所以等于是
有这种属于有点中高价的
然后像刚刚讲的
几十块的转机股
反正本益比都那么高了
那几十块的转机
应该也很有吸引力才对
没错 所以大家如果看基本面
其实有点难做CPU
没错
大家可以看一下量价
跟技术面上的形态
好 所以這邊的話
喜歡CPU的朋友
其實CPU有節奏的
先反彈的可能會是
所謂的老CPU
一線CPU像聯亞就領軍了
可是接下來就會有擴散效應
這幾天雖然台股創歷史新高
可是不是台積電帶動的
反而很多中小型的低價股
非常的活潑
大家可以著亮的試試看
因為進場的成本跟壓力
會比較低一點點
可是他們的基本面不好參考
所以一定要看他們的技術型態
来做操作
那如果需要今天所有的图卡资料
欢迎订阅一下我们赵华艾伦说的
YouTube频道
我们会把它放在首页的天文栏
尤其是等一下的大来宾
过去是半导体产业的工程师
转入了当产业分析师
准备了超过20张的产业头影片
需要的朋友真的要把我们订阅起来
等一下我们就来欢迎大来宾吧
欢迎回到赵华
艾伦说
我想要问艾伦
如果让你重新选择一次职业
你会选什么呢
可以选那种
譬如说郭台铭的儿子
不是职业
不是选投胎
这样不是职业
儿子这个身份
不是
我选什么
我希望可以不要被管的职业
现在也没人管你
所以就可能还是会是
以这个方向出发
对
不要管我
是
对
叛逆的个性是不是
但是我们今天的大来宾很厉害
是
他其实有机会
或是他当过人人称现的半导体工程师
要是到现在可能分红一年都几个亿了
可是他却选择当分析师
到底哪里想不开呢
我们先来欢迎他
就是普惠头顾的我们的半导体分析师
黎智健 Vic
哈喽大家好
我是Vic
很发翘耶
大家沒辦法當工程師
但是很花笑沒關係
因為Vic有一個座右銘
花落盛開
蝴蝶自來
對 這個剛才有人講
這個如果是蒼蠅的話
代表這個花不是很好的花
可是以前就看到這句話
你們應該有聽過對不對
因為我發現就是當這個做得很好
不管在各行各業做得很好
然後身邊就會有很多資源
開始往他靠近
你會發現
那個很成功的人
不用請客
別人都請他
明明他口袋錢最多
是
然後再來就是
如果衍生出來的話
當然我們期許自己
能夠變成一個盛開的花
對不對
現在還在
還在含苞待放
然後但是呢
如果
飲用到股市也可以
是
是不是
這個有些好的公司
他其實盛開的時候
就發現資金開始湧出
然後一天成交量幾十萬張
可是在這個
很多新聞
消息還沒出來之前
他的基本面
還沒被大家看到的時候
欸 乏人問津
我覺得都一樣道理
好 Vic 的意思是
因為他是一朵美麗的花
所以他愛開在哪裡
蝴蝶都會來找他
我希望未來有機會
不是蒼蠅
是是
但是還是要問了
因為這兩個行業應該都不錯
但是半導體工程師
可能大家會更有感覺啊
分紅啊
配股 股價都上千元啊
為什麼不繼續當工程師
要來當產業分析師
其實我覺得跟艾倫講是一樣
不想要被管
這個當到後面
當著人家都說
這個做得高不如做得穩
領得多不如領得久
所以當到這個高階主管之後
我發現這個壓力
其實真的是不成比例的變大
然後也不太想說
受制在這個體系裡面
反而發現了另一個興趣
就投資
大家其實都有投資的興趣
每個人都想要在辦公室
廁所裡都會有投資的興趣
但是我發現我那個興趣是很濃厚的
我在這個出差的飛機上面
我不是在看公司的報告
我都在看那個縣途所以呢你們的薪水小偷對啊 薪水小偷出差的飛機上那時間是我的然後所以呢就會想說那未來我要當一個分析師然後結果剛好有機會
就是因為認識了老王嘛
然後呢他也在
他說你有產業的經驗
那過去的分析師其實
大部分都是財經背景
金融背景
那你是產業出來的
而且你從這個底下的
這個產品工程師
一直到行銷
一直到這個策略
那你都知道
那你原始來這邊
有一個發揮的地方
然後我就覺得還不錯
所以我就去考分析師
所以我覺得不錯
是因為你念的是理工科對不對
理工科出來的話
你先選擇進產業
再進來當分析師
可是如果你念的是商學相關的
就不一定能進去當半導體工程師了
是啊
其實我是不務正業
當初也有去面試排氣店
如果面試排氣店
現在就不會有FIC了
你就會待在那裡是不是
我就待在那裡了
我前幾天才一個學長
才密我
他說
你是XXX老師的學生嗎
我是你學長
然後我說學長好你在哪裡
他說他在台積電17年
是
哇這個
我覺得如果我再繼續在那邊的話
應該也是不錯的啦
喔那你可以把學長挖過來當產業分析師啊
學長現在人家成就很好的
是我們要現在跟他看齊
但是我覺得很厲害的一點是
因為Vic真的待過產業
所以目前你可以分辨的出來
現在大家都在長嘛
因為AI時代
我們台灣得天獨厚
幾乎每一個領域都說跟 AI 有關
可是漲到這裡
你覺得誰是被低估的
當然誰可能已經 price in 了
其實我覺得百花齊放
就很多產業它都在成長中
都在缺料中
技術都在進步中
那但是有些股價已經在反應中
那我覺得目前仍然是合理的
像最近的這個先進封裝
封裝相關的族群
那算是合理
另外 CCL ABF 還有 MLCC
因為做了一個比較大的修正
所以反而在合理的區間內
但是啊 最近有一些
大家常常就是念的出口的一些專有名詞
以前都不認識的
比如說 CPO啦
FOP、OP啦
玻璃基板、TGB
那這種反而很難評估
所以你不能說它是合理還是不合理
有的已經反應很合理 超過了
但有的還是不合理
因為它未來的這個成長
它是有這種翻倍的機會
所以有些很難評估
再來呢 我覺得有些是被低估
你明明看到它未來成長性很高
或是說甚至連八月份
繳出來的成績單都是很好的
可是呢就是不反應
就是不反應
像是電力啊或是像產物工程
明明在手訂單這麼多
合約負債這麼高
可是股價就是相對疲弱
但是未來還是看得見
這個可能要有信念
因為我們常常講
會不會股價不漲就是它背後的問題
但你覺得這個產業真的沒問題
對啊因為
AI是在泡沫之前
不管泡沫還是泡沫之後
它的這個 input
always是電力嘛
那電力進來以後才有 output 才有 token
不管在訓練的時候
還是在推論的時候都需要很多的電力
我們從很多報告可以看出來
目前 AI 的電力荒
從明年開始有非常大的缺口
一直不斷產生
那有哪些缺口
我可以自己 cue 下一頁
好 因為今天 MEC 準備的資料非常多
對 我們翻頁的速度比翻頁還快
這個大家會很擔心
因為很多雜音
包含AI要放緩速度
或是說地方政府開始叫這些AI Data Center
賣一點蓋
或是不給你核准權
但是實際上影響並不高
我們實際上去看
它到底影響多少
數字能夠說話
譬如說300個地方政府
實際上只有影響2.3GW
2.3到底是多還是少
我不知道對不對
可是我們看到明年
有38GW
是兩倍在成長中
而且這是核准的
可以繼續走的
所以比例上一看大家就知道
其實影響並不大對不對
進行中的
而且很多透過他們
BTM的部分
就是背後的 meter
他們自己可以自備電力
自己去產生電
所以會跟像 BE 這種公司合作
更快的可以產生出電
給 Data Center 用
那這種情況下核准機率又變高了
再加上有些只是暫緩而已
可能三四個月之後
它又合可了嘛 對不對
因為這種競賽大家不能落後
那我們可以看到
機櫃的數量持續在翻倍中
而且價格
就是它的含金量也越來越高
那這個部分大家不要太疑慮
未來還是持續在電力上有很大的需求
地方政府會這樣限制
也是因為他們覺得電力或基礎設施來不及是不是
對 沒有錯
因為很多的這個Data Center
其實受惠的還是CSP業者
對於一般居民
哇 這些電力設施在我隔壁
我才不要 我賺不到錢
這不是台灣很容易發生
美國地不是很大嗎
對啊 不然就免費
German Lite 給人家用嘛 對不對
這種基本上公關要做好
那這樣子就會很快就合可
然後 可是從這個
瓦特到幾個瓦
其實為什麼
因為每個這個 GPU
它使用的電量越來越高
從過去40到50kW
然後一直到這個整個機櫃
現在可能上看750kW這樣子
那需要的電力越高
它就去對於伺服器的電源的燙
就是整個市場需求
成長率你知道高達多少嗎
我看一下數字我嚇到
因為我過去常來理財商的秀
我們常常講說你看CaGR Cag
這35%值得注意
70%
70%的成長
所以全球製造中心的電量需求量
你看超級高
那裡面會有一個到2030年有一個缺口
是268GbW
還記得上一頁我們說
明年會有多少嗎
我們回顧一下
明年38
是
缺口
你就知道
這真的是缺口非常的大
那缺口這麼大的情況下
升電
然後電怎麼轉到這個 data center 裡面去轉換進去
然後到 data center 裡面怎麼轉換到這個 grid to chip
就是到 chip 端怎麼用到這個電
我覺得這裡面就產生很多的商機
因為它的缺口這麼大
所以要如火如荼的
增加這些基礎設施
沒錯
好
像這個大廠
Trainforce 就發布有電力缺口
再來呢
輝達的部分跟 Google 結盟
他們看
Hupon影辦
趕快來做
電力的部分有問題了
因為他們發現
過去像GPU在算力的部分
然後
這個我們可能還在散熱的部分也很重視
發現電力也不行
要趕快來
所以Hupon影辦
像Google跟輝達結AEMA的聯盟
另外Amazon也入股
Jana AEC這間公司
所以股價一天跳空30%
我覺得有點激勵這個族群的感覺
過來 Google 它也跟歐洲的分岸的公司
簽這個 150 億美元的 PPA
這是 Power Purchase Agreement
就是有一個 22 年的很長的一個採購合約
因為它在歐洲建 Data Center 一定要電
那這個核電的部分是它的選擇之一
如果它沒有保障好它的來電的話
它就沒有 Output 沒有 Token 可以用
那可是就是跟不上 AI 的速度
美國基礎電力設施
其實我們可以從幾個數據來看出來
剛才說到這個跳空30%
是
那這個JANET AC
那除了它以外
其實我把這幾家
大家可以特別留意一下
觀察一下
最終一下這幾家
像這個Vertif
Eaton
或是GE
或是這個廣達
不是台灣的廣達
是美國的廣達
或是Bloom Energy
這幾家公司都有幾個狀況
比如說營收年增
然後創新高
然後再來是Q2調整之後
創高 裁車上修
再來在手訂單 創新高
在手訂單很高 雙雙創高
再來這個手計破10億美元
由虧轉移
從這些跡象可以看得出來
這些公司雖然都在右下角
大家可以去看右下角
主要是因為過去的這個
4WP1還是相對比較高一點
所以做了一個修正
那修正完畢之後呢
看到未來實際上並沒有變
那花若盛開 蝴蝶自來
我覺得未來蝴蝶就會來
他們之前股價多多少少也強勢過
可是你看這一波Meta大漲
然後MD創新高
Intel也在大漲
那他們為什麼
需求剛剛前面看了那麼多
還沒有辦法輪到他們呢
主要就是因為
過去的那個我剛才提到的PE有點高
包含我們台灣的台大電
是
過去它的PE可能到了40倍以上
你就覺得不可思議
以前台大電呢
你怎麼算怎麼算
就450塊就是緊繃了
那朋友問我說450塊賣掉
就我愛賣掉就賣飛了
直接飆到2500塊
可是到了2500塊
你再回頭去看的時候
當你看台牙店的4-World PE
你會怕點
你會覺得說
要休息一下
當你當初在看跌回來的旗紅
你會覺得
不會怕
因為4-World PE
你看到未來
就獲利就擺在那邊
你不會怕
所以我覺得這個部分
它的速度
就必須要讓時間去發酵
你要等它
就像小孩子長大
你不能在那邊很急
要不要助長
這個東西就是要時間
待會我們看他們的今年的獲利跟明年獲利預估
你會覺得說還不錯
實際上更厲害的是後年的預估
是因為Vertif 或者是像B會連到台灣什麼
齊鴻 高麗 他們都很厲害
對啊
鴻和台股這波比較厲害
對上次來講電源講這個散熱
還有散熱沒事
現在只好來講電源
來救救電源
你看看這一排
重電股
好辛苦
艾倫都沒在講
因為這不符合動能
這不行
這個右側交易的完全不行
你看
可是雖然不行
主要是因為過去它的本益比
因為它過去成長很高
大家用這種折線估值一折回來
哇這個像這個華盛可能一千多塊
然後什麼的
但是折線是把未來都算進來
可是你發現說
它本益比就變相對比較高一點
它也修正了很久
整理了很久
但是這些人你看它的訂單
AIDC的這個訂單從121到200億
是不是衝高了
然後外銷比重也很高
也打進STARGAT
那另外像市電
再手訂單600億
能見度
這不是我寫的喔
我去找資料的
到29 30耶
是
可以講到這麼遠嗎
可以喔
明年的我覺得都有點變數
沒關係
至少人家是樂觀的
然後過來像中興電
過去也因為是軍工
它有一些
弊案的疑慮
所以嘛
你看在這裡面
相對本益比它就比較低一些些
那實際上人家還是有賺錢的
而且它是GIS的龍頭
在台灣裡面有很多這種
就是我們的伺服器中心
裡面的像冷氣、電機
超過應該七、八成都是它在做的
在手訂單
也有默默的在耕耘
不是沒做事
雖然說股價很弱
但是人家還是有做事
能見度到2029
那其他像大同東元
也是就是紛紛的開始轉換到
跟像Meta合作
或是跟資料中心合作
好 那這一組的話
本一筆相對都很合理了
本來之前大家都滑成50倍
現在也默默的回到30幾倍了
對喔 是是是
所以在這裡面我覺得
最近有點整理
大家都不敢講的一檔股票
勇者 勇者來了
那這個中心電
它第二季營收稍微也激增了
16% 年增6%
有回來重點是毛利率
創進行新高
我覺得這代表產品組合做得還不錯
再來呢
今年也跨入AI Data Center裡面的一些
統包啊 或是一些工程
那中華電信跟四方在台灣啊
主要是他的客戶這樣子
加動率
加動率有100%以上喔
他加動率這麼高啊
對 120%
其實就是有點加班的意思啦
因為我們以前的加動率大概就是
你差不多90% 80%就很滿了
如果你要再高一點點就是
可能把辦公室拿來做啊
沒有啦
就是加班 然後辦公室拿來做
比平常的這種
這個產能還要再高出一點
所以加動率比較高
再來資本支出小修啊
小修上修到15到21
代表人家還是有點企圖心
那骨架呢
這個要問艾倫了
看起來
感覺起來
怎麼樣下一頁我本來想把包丟給他了結果不是 他不是快表態的陣上所有均線嗎是 其實還不錯啊就差放量一根紅K
差一點量 沒有量
技術分析大師
對 是是
觀察啦 我們都是觀察一下嘛 對不對
那另外我們也可以看到這個Pulse Supply Unit
它的佔比啊 有些人看到這個報告的時候
其實有點怕掉 會覺得說
你看它的占比就是綠色那部分
這個嗎?
綠色
是
你有沒有覺得笑到
14%到8%
是
到202627以上就開始8%
可是實際上是因為
GPU的價格越來越高
因為我們很少看到你會挑那個占比越來越小的來講
是是是是
這故意挑的
是故意挑的
那原因是GPU的價格越來越高
加上它GPU啊
它配套的措施
譬如說
一冷散熱啊
機櫃啦
這些都是變成說它的
Power supply unit的占比變少
可是要再附上這個
就是吃藥的時候要配水的意思一樣
你要知道
它的這個Power supply unit金額持續增加
而且是大幅增加
我們剛才說有一個69%很厲害了
我們這邊就看到一個巨怪
這個大物 120%
Cag 120%
也就是說它雖然的占比變少
但數量跟金額是這樣提升的
原因是因為它的含金量很高
從過去的 Harper 0.42 per watt
就是每一瓦
到了這個 VeroVit
Arboron 它是 0.93 耶
這成了幾乎兩倍以上
所以相關的
這個整個 Pulse Part Unit 裡面
沒有那麼小啦 那麼長
這裡面有很多供應鏈
譬如說 PSU 的廠商
功率元件
磁性元件 電容散熱
因為也要散熱
這個功率也會高 它需要散熱
再來這個固態變壓器
電源 PMIC 控制 IC 都會受惠
因為這裡面的需求
規格技術提升
所以這些人都有機會
隨著技術提升
然後他的含金量就增加
不過電源供應器廠商
大廠小廠很多
然後供應元件的話
等一下也會聊
6月的時候說什麼
市場上都買不到供應元件
結果7月的時候跌得稀巴爛
可是電源的部分
其實是一直在跌代
一直在升級的
從過去啊
像這個過去伺服器的一邊
1.1到3kW
然後到近期的這個
5.5到12kW
大部分就 5.5到 12kW
然後呢
到了
接著要 400 到 800 伏
你們想一下裡面的這些銅線
這麼粗一根嗎
那個廠商會破廠
因為那個價格很高
所以我們必須要把這個電壓提高
800 伏是不得不
有些人會擔憂說
這個800 伏可能沒有會延後
我想跟大家講
比大家想的樂觀
有些人說要到 2028
我覺得 2027 就會開始
有佔比會提升了
然後再來到未來就是 SST 固態變壓
固態變壓器
好 那除了它以外
在櫃子裡面或櫃子外面
也會搭配一些BBU
所以BBU最近
老實說也沒有什麼表現
但是這個有人說BBU不是標配
不是百分之百用
我確定不是百分之百
可是它的比重會越來越提升
從過去的10%
一直到50%到60%以上
那過去的機期很低
機期很低
它的價格呢
從720 到未來是24000 塊
你看看這成長有多大
那過去機器第一
明年開始出貨
那明年呢
後年呢
大後年呢
成長就會很大
所以我今天提出來的數字
其實都還滿大的
這都不是我自己去key的啦
自己key我就key 369
那什麼
這是研究機構去看的
他們去統計
這就很
很VU持續在成長中
所以
來到低機器的計算
今年低機器
那明年呢
開始出貨
那明年我相信股價就會有所反應
好 整條電力供應鏈
感覺上我們台廠應該是很佔便宜
電源供應器也很多家
BBU也很多家在做
但是也是同樣的問題
就是在股價上面
對 好像市場的共識沒有辦法非常凝聚
對
這裡面就很多廠商
至於是這些人讓他們共識沒有凝聚
例如說
我最常講 ASKY
對 ASKY
不會漲就是不會漲
然後台達店前一陣子
落難成什麼樣子
沒錯 對
那我們就怪他
不要怪我們
沒有啦
就是公司
沒有 其實是跟
我覺得像台達店的董事長
是鄭平鄭董事長
他其實在法說會裡面
他的回應都是比較平穩老實的
譬如說他就說
我們毛利率
我們沒有看那麼高
毛利率看到什麼
38 39 35就OK啦
我們會好好做好
配合客戶之類的
的確出來就是35不近
這個他意思 我覺得這種誠實
總比你一直過度 一直在講 一直在講
然後呢
可是呢
這個公司交出來成績單卻不如預期
那可以看到
他把資本支出也提高到700億
代表說
實際上公司是很穩健的
在接未來的訂單
在準備未來的訂單
我們看到他是被評為
Grid to Chip
就是從電網一直到
chip 就是晶片的部分
最完整
甚至還遇過
雖然剛才那個市值整個是成長對不對
需求整個成長
它占有率居然是成長
很多都是市場價值增加
可是我占有率會越來越少
它不是 它會增加
所以我覺得
看到二六年四十一塊
二七年六十三塊
我這邊沒有寫二八年
我寫在這邊
哇 其實你要讓它有一點時間
所以買的人請看2028
這中間都不要來找我
沒有
有修正就是很好的機會嗎
真的啊
修正到一千六以下
是啊 沒有修正怎麼買呢
對不對
再來光寶的部分其實也表現很好
過去因為台達電它本益比相對比較高
但光寶的本益比相對就比較低了
所以兩個就有點拉近
現在兩個拉到算是一個比較合理
那就是大家可以介入的一個機會嘛對不對
然後另外除了HBDC
我們聽到常聽到光寶啊 台達
也可以聽到像康舒嘛
康舒圈聯目標也希望能夠達到30%
也有推出1MW的這個HBDC
那主要它還是跟這個Bloom Energy BE合作啦
所以BE概念股
他想到就高利
他想到就康舒
所以也可以留意
兩樣勤耶
高利創高
康舒躺在地上
高利今天就漲停對不對
然後呢
其他像
計電器就比較少人講
我覺得可以留意一下計電器
是
而relay的部分嘛
他主要就是負責這個保護嘛
做高電流高耐壓的部分是保護
所以
未來呢
這個傳統的relay
轉型做這個AIDC的relay
它的成長
看得出來很明顯
可以留意一下
其他呢
就是BVU的部分
新盛利、順達、ASKY
我覺得是我比較注意的這三個BVU的股票
好 但是大廠就ASKY
大家就覺得這股價沒意思
順達跟新盛利相對比較活潑
這是今天最新的KBOB
這是覺得這個
高點在這兒呢 還有戲吧
我覺得有機會啦
這個外資也是給它一個比較高的評價
近期啦
那他們也是看到比較遠一點點
如果你看很短線的話
的確股價短線很難預測
要問照艾倫
可是如果看比較
還不錯
短線也不錯
那長線我也覺得不錯
兩隻腳打好了
然後另外順達的部分
他這時候有這個外資發報告
就變得很活潑
活潑兩天就沒有了
可是經過這個整理完畢之後
我反而覺得
只要基本面沒有變的話
未來的這個題材也沒變
那訂單也在那邊的情況下
反而呢
這個
套用艾倫有時候
三角修煉
有看節目
然後呢這種情況下
滿不離
這個稍微有一點動能之後
然後我們就來觀察看看好不好
這個是在BBU的部分
還有電源供應器
其實台大電是很多元的
是
還有誰呢
最後總點名
終於
因為超過時間有點多
我就講一下
那除了這裡外
功率元件
對功率元件
這個今天禮拜二
禮拜二
我们有看到这个媒体也有在提说
像国外的厂商
国外大厂
像这个Ansemi他们
他们也在酝酿
10月10号双十国庆祝台湾去涨价
可是Ansemi涨价不是今天的效果
对不是
其实一直以来都有
他们有些厂商已经自己在涨价了
对
已经在涨价
那整个这个电源的需求技术提升
然后它的这个伏特数增加
对于公路元件要求其实是更高的
它這個耐壓程度
其實真的在做開關是誰你知道嗎
就是功率元件
就是要開關開關
不管是二極體還是MOSFET
功率的是叫PowerMOSFET
都是他們在做工的
他們做工很辛苦
那很辛苦呢
股價我覺得近期有一點
也蠻辛苦的
但是至少我覺得它心跳聲還蠻大聲的
就是有些呢
有些還蠻活潑的
3.5分給你跳一下
到7.8%掌停
但是整體來說還在整理
比如說像恰茂是整個比較
這個規模比較大一點
然後在AI跟車用三軌並進
那今年AI的營收目標也會到15%
我覺得這裡面呢
就是最活潑成長最兇猛
有些就是投資人比較喜歡
就是那種成長很猛的
過去他的AI的佔比很少
可是現在佔比就忽然間變高了
年增114%的營收
然後累增91%
然後從13%的佔比變成47%的佔比
那 PowerMOSFET 佔六成
那未來也是佈 比如這個燙化系
HPDC 所以如果你喜歡猛 猛爆性的
你希望這種就是
業績看起來高成長
業績看起來高成長 有爆發性的
那你可以留意一下它
那另外 最近只是大封測時代
我前幾天也有看
所以大封測時代的情況下
那這個功率圓件有沒有封測
有 傑銘
這個傑銘也是一樣
它這個封裝測試代工廠
可是啊
股價你看它的本益比相對
你看如果說今年有機會賺9到10塊
股價是不是相對便宜啊
主要是大家會有疑慮啦
就是說它產能都在什麼合肥啊
然後這些地方
那地緣風險政治的比較高一點點
可是人家的訂單
人家的獲利是擺在眼前的
還是有機會反應啦
可以留意一下
如果你覺得你也想要風車
想要本益比低一點的
可以考慮一下
最後呢
舉例說明強茂跟你剛剛講的
爆充型的廣紅科
對
因為強茂是整體來講的話
就是比較四比八穩
有規模
有這個Cash Cloud
Cash Cloud
就是像這個車用的部分
它在貢獻
所以整體來講是四比八穩
沒什麼問題
那近期也是一樣
這個畫線有點遠
我要稍微畫一下
因為有點持續
然後墊高
佔回所有均線
那當然前面這邊看起來
跌得比較快
這個套牢
可能冤魂重重
不過我們就觀察它一下
然後再來呢 是廣紅科的部分
也是一樣
這個
它怎麼股價沒暴衝啊
營收暴衝比較不開業
欸 這邊有暴衝過一次喔
這邊有暴衝過一次喔
這邊的話就是剛剛講
六月的時候說什麼
市場上買不到功率元件
對
瞬間大家都買到了
對 大家買到了
不看下一頁
沒有了
有下一頁
還真的還有下一頁
對
你就知道你準備了多少東西吧
還好
但他們都躺在這裡
所以大家是很有時間
在台股創新高的時候
找到潛力低估的
是 那就如我剛才提到的
它因為有中國製造的疑慮
但是本一比相對比較低一點點
今年獲利是比較穩健一些
股價也在這邊
那左側交易的人
自己去找機會找買點
那右側交易的人就等他站回去
是 好
所以今天因為台股創新高
Vic帶來了
明明大家都在歡聲鼓舞
可是他們卻相對被低估的
所以非常謝謝Vic
因為我們需要了解產業的發展
你是給我們一個信心
這個產業的發展是沒有問題的
只是現在市場的資金需要領居一個共襲
絕錯了
好 如果他們回來的話
不要又變成買不到買不到買不到
對
希望能夠買不到
對啊 可是為什麼那時候市場會有這些傳言啊
就在漲的時候就會